[Music]
hi guys welcome to my house I'm Karina
and didn't even come on so this room is
my office
and probably the most used room in my
house we have my favorite picture of
Steven looking as grumpy as ever
Steven is a French Bulldog is about two
years and probably my favorite fur baby
ever my baby Marco would be that it's
okay to breathe I put it all over the
house it probably sounds silly but
sometimes we think that life is an
emergency and we're just rushing and
sometimes it's really good to just take
a minute to breathe and understand where
you're at and how I've come and how well
you're doing on that day over here I've
got probably my most happiest memory of
YouTube at the moment this is my
Allinger thousand and while about
300,000 now but when they send this to
me I was totally surprised as oten it
was something they did and it was nice
to know that the powers that be at
YouTube knew I existed
so YouTube started for me because I was
working marketing and it just wasn't my
dream career and I didn't know how to
find it like if you don't know what your
talents are you can't go to university
or study because you just don't know
what you're meant to do so I can YouTube
and treat it like a video diary and I
tested out all my different hobbies and
as soon as my subscribers that made me
realize that I had such a passion for
fitness and they will ask me if I were
personal trainer people will ask you if
we could meet our some life now together
and I realized that actually maybe
exercise for something I wanted to do so
I took on the course while working
full-time and I quit my job
it came fully employed as a personal
trainer and then the YouTube grew
alongside I do get some incredible
emails from my followers and they're
kind of saying that I've helped change
their lives and I work with the mobile
young kids and eating disorders is the
feeling of changing people 5 is success
so now we're going take you upstairs the
best-fit which is the food and i'll be
showing you guys my favorite smoothie
recipe
[Music]
let's get breakfast it is my favorite
another day I go substantive influence
when I wake up so hungry so this is
media so we must have heavy breakfast
you could have it post or pre workout
and it's super simple you can change it
around if you have any dietary
requirements so all we need is one
banana which I'm going to pop into my
blender just in half then I'm going to
add the ice next I'm going to ask you is
respect to Christine one of my favorite
things bunny hardly taste them and then
some flax seeds as well as good to get
some extra nutrients in and it's really
good for fiber so enough protein you can
use any person because once you this is
one of my favorites because it's
chocolate flavored foot and I'm just
going to put two scoops in just what I
would normally have if I was going to
Jim if I have an integer then just one
then we're going to use the oat milk now
I'm pretty simple and I just pop it so
about here but if you want to you it's
about cup and a half all I've seen is
length I thought Lisa just make
everything in a clip 16 and definitely
make you feel like you two enjoy your
breakfast a lot more if you want think
about in the fridge we could make it
before you know to the workout or you
can have it afterwards and it plays a
moving
[Music]
so we now in my bedroom I'm going to get
you to sew of my favorite tier mountain
then you guys help inform a prophetic I
love a baddie talk because I know how
much America sweat and then I need wagon
so I can reach after the highway spam
shove this middle of a sexy and you know
it's in a welcome to song because
everyone likes clubs and CrossFit so
you're going to need to have you back
outfit but I'm gonna go join my friends
without yoga workout and eautiful outfit
this is the Inca and be different
classified and I just love to teach and
class the owners and he knows realistic
we're going up this outfit for the day
when you're getting a classic and
quickly us immediately spinning or some
stick right loop or finishing your sexy
uncomfortably wanna make sure your
family is on there see the main final
outfit if I was going to go running so
one baggy t-shirt because we know it's
going to come off at some point
and secondly most important is imploding
stay up Midwest and running and get
changed
and apparently thing is a gives me Obama
which is why I love these alone so yeah
this would be my perfect running outfit
so finally I'm going in to see what
attach in my gym bag but I use
depressive archetype it ages when
companies people can't be but fits or my
gosh I use a big thick so first up it
was taking a different route one because
it some traveling all the equipment I'm
on is being used then I will just do
this because it's super simple
next a water bottle and I have this
delicate one because let's face it we
love to shake it and pop my eye strings
which have previously made in here
sometime and a half because you know
what it's like when your hair gets super
sweaty off your work out so this is
always a bit cool now in my makeup bag
it's just a couple of essentials and a
few calories I think you guys will
really like so I like to smell good if
I'm gonna trainers I've been why I'm not
smelling it and it says Jane alone Marin
tompa smells amazing Alex honest ones at
last
okay perfect if you're sweating and then
I have my third Soviet people everything
everyone I like that I shattered
everything all in one
I don't think Americans with me and
Fritz up my face afterwards Lancome
andragogy is loyal performance again so
they're more hydrated okay so finally
I'm around my face and my face along
eyes at these are few days when a heavy
glamour okay so for deities or more of
my face detection Irina and if you like
my freaky side so enjoy my house I would
be everything remember subscribe
[Music]